[Music]
welcome to another episode of vmn a show
where you have a vm skeptic and a vm
enthusiast come together hash out all
things cloud computer compute related uh
brian thank you so much for being here
today i've got some questions for you
hello hello i'm excited today databases
and vms it's my happy place
and because of that i wanted to bring in
gabe weiss who's one of our colleagues
and expert in databases hi gabe hey
everybody yes happy to get into it i
guess i'm just gonna dive right in if
that's cool
i want to know
when it comes to data on the cloud with
compute and whatnot why not just let a
managed service run it for me magically
why would i want to run the database
level at the compute level like why does
that make sense i mean why not indeed
right
the demo answer that we always give it
depends uh there is nothing wrong with
running a database on a vm in the cloud
that's let's let be clear right away
cloud sql which is our relational
database managed offering it runs in a
vm so whether you're running in your vm
or rvm you're still running in a vm the
the differences and why you might want
to run your own is really comes down to
one of requirements if
you have a legacy system you've got an
application you've been running forever
and it has a set of requirements then a
managed database might not satisfy those
one of the things with managed databases
is we manage it for you which means we
restrict what you can do with it right
okay so let's be
specific what are what are the kinds of
things that you know might push you into
kind of running it yourself on a vm
right so you know i bring up like if
you've got this legacy system if you've
got an application that you've been
running for you know a couple of decades
it builds up over time what you add to
it when you have requirements what you
need so a real good concrete example of
this is take like sql server one of the
big things with sql servers are stored
procedures you've got these methods that
run on the database itself stored
procedures have certain requirements
sometimes like maybe they require a
super user if you're running on a
managed database we don't give you a
proper super user because we have this
um we have to protect the database for
you we have an sla a service level
agreement where we guarantee that the
database is going to be up
all the time for you right like you you
hear some people talk about the nines
the nines is your sort of percent of um
how much uptime we guarantee cloud sql
for example our managed offering is
99.95
available three and a half nines which
means you know it's like 20 minutes of
downtime a month or something like that
so
with these extensions
or the the stored procedures we have to
guard that up time which means we don't
give you everything so if you've got a
system that requires that
a managed system might not work for you
okay that actually makes a lot of sense
and i appreciate you for bringing in
that perspective
so now my question is what about someone
that uh
maybe doesn't have uh their database in
the cloud yet but they're thinking about
switching over what's the process for
that right so you know you're talking
about like we call it the green field
where um new application uh a new
company that's thinking like where
should i put my stuff everything's
moving to the cloud like let's be to be
clear that this what we're seeing in the
industry right is everyone wants their
data in the cloud for a whole host of
reasons you want to run analytics on
your data um you've got a global
situation where you've got an
application that needs global access
you're going to be in the cloud so i
always say if you haven't got something
already
start with the managed service right you
don't want to set up all the boilerplate
stuff that you're going to have to do to
run your own database the hardware
management all the operating system and
security updates managing the database
health itself doing all you know making
sure that the machine is healthy with a
managed service all that's handled for
you you don't have to do any of that
stuff so if you're starting fresh
absolutely start with a managed service
well you just said it right there you're
kind of um i love it when you're
starting a new project and you get to
like set everything up from scratch but
a lot of us are dealing with a lot of
software that already exists like what
do you do in that scenario so if you've
got one of those legacy systems like i
said right like the 20-year application
you're working with there's a few
different ways you could do it there's
if your systems are all really tightly
integrated and you've got it running in
like a tight cluster
of machines or something you can just do
that the the lift and shift right just
take the entire thing throw it up in a
vm and now instead of running in your
closet you're running in our closet but
we handle all the machine health for you
so that's absolutely a valid strategy if
you need to get out of where you're at
and get to the cloud first just put
everything in a vm and get going you do
want to split the data out though right
so strategically speaking if you if your
requirements get to the cloud first do
that lift and shift up then start
working on splitting off your data
there are cases though where that might
not be the case if you've got an
application that
for
compliance reasons or other you have to
have the application local but your data
has now grown beyond where it can handle
and you need to just get the data out
splitting the data out is totally fine
too
but there's a there's some problems
there right so the internet the
internet's a problem right
so
if you are in a situation where you want
to keep your application but you need to
move the data that's fine but you should
be aware that you'll have to handle that
on the application side so
great connection to your data center
maybe you've got a 30 millisecond ping
time round trip right
if you're running locally you're ping to
your databases less than a millisecond
for a really well-tuned relational
database so all of a sudden your times
30 but it's not even that kind because
let's say for example you're only
allowing ssl connections to your
database the tls handshake to establish
that connection takes two round trips
back and forth to establish the
handshake before you get to the data so
now it's not 30 milliseconds to get your
answer it's 100 milliseconds to get your
answer and then a bunch of apps like
make a bunch of queries in a row and so
that just like every one of those
extends it out so
what
what should people do in that kind of
like what do you do about that i mean
you can't fix the internet the internet
you're kind of stuck with but the like
the tons of
connections the queries that you talked
about right some applications because
they're used to this quick turnaround
time they'll just spin up a connection
ask their questions shut down the
connection if you do that a couple
hundred times and your round trip is now
not so quick that's terr that's gonna
like wreck your your uh responsive ui so
instead
the first thing that i tell people is
the first thing you want to do is what
we call client-side connection pooling
most libraries that you connect with so
there's like for python we recommend
sql alchemy is a great library to use
for connecting to your relational
databases there's objects that you use
to create the connection and there's a
connection object and there's a pool
object that pool is a connection pool
that will establish you a connection to
the database and it holds it open for
whatever you specify that means if
you're making these like hundreds of
queries you know every second that's
great it'll establish one connection run
all your queries until there's some idle
time then shut it down so that cuts down
your round trip time because the round
trip time for that security is only on
that initial connection and then after
that you're good to go right this is
this is really interesting to me because
you know i i like that you said earlier
you know if you're starting greenfield
go manage use the managed service that's
the easy easy move um and then i can see
how it gets a lot more complicated
depending on your needs
the one thing i think that shouldn't be
complicated is actually moving to the
cloud
and so are there tools or anything
to help make that a smoother process it
like you said it shouldn't be
and there are absolutely cases where it
is right there's totally cases where
just moving the data is hard the one of
the biggest problems with
moving your data is the the boilerplate
way to do this in a lot of cases is what
they call the export import which is you
go to your database you hit a button and
it dumps all of your data to this giant
file and then on the new instance you
hit import and it sucks it all into the
new one and you're good to go that's
kind of what you're like the old school
classic way that you do this stuff but
if you've got terabytes of data it's
kind of tough to do that and while
you're doing the import well now what
unless you shut everyone down and say
okay no one touched the database we're
doing a migration now you've got data
that continues to come in while you're
importing so the gap between when you've
hit the export export button and when
you do the import there's this data that
you're missing that you have to catch up
still there's other ways you can do it
you can set up replication between two
servers there's um which basically means
the current database that you're moving
away from you set up as the primary you
set up a replica and say okay now move
all the data over and it'll do it it
streams it across the pipe it's kind of
a pain to set up there's a bunch of like
little knobs to make that easier we've
got a service it's called database
migration service dms
and that basically handles it still uses
the database native ways to do it so
like for example on postgres we use pg
logical as a the way we do migrations
and it will
handle all the connections all the
connectivity you define
a source object your source database in
the ui and then it creates a cloud sql
instance for you and then it moves it
now keeping in mind this is only for
managed service so if you're moving to a
managed service this is the tool to do
it if you want to run your own in a vm
you're kind of on your own because it's
not managed for you so you have to do
all of these pieces you can still do it
there's still ways to set up external
replicas uh and external primary
instances to do it
but you're on your own so dms is kind of
that easy way to move to a managed
service okay that's super cool because i
have definitely lived the um try to
schedule a window where you can shut
everything down with all the people
involved and then hope everything works
right and you don't have to like revert
or whatever thing and that
that's hard so it's nice to know that
there's some tools to make that easier
now so all right to summarize what we
just learned today just uh just to recap
everything you came into it
i still want to hold up that my managed
databases can and should be used in a
lot of instances but there are other
instances where it doesn't make sense to
use them where there's some capability
that you need that's not provided yet um
or maybe just the way your system is set
up uh but if you're trying to transfer
over then there's database management
system which makes it a lot smoother of
a process did i did i did i get that
exactly and it all comes down to your
requirements right like you said nothing
wrong with running a database in the vm
as long as you're comfortable managing
it if you don't want to worry about that
managed services are great so if people
want to dig in and kind of learn more
about this
do you have any recommendations oh yeah
so uh you know the dms the database
migration service documentation on our
site is a great place to start there's a
lot of good links there um it talks a
lot about the kind of the strategies
that i i talked about and it will lead
you into sort of getting comfortable
with the idea of moving your data around
uh for other stuff like there's a ton of
blog posts we got a lot of um blog
material on our gcp blog around like
managed service versus running your own
um
what kind of there's troubleshooting
like there's a couple ones that are like
troubleshooting i wrote one on
connectivity but networking is really
hard just in general uh so i have a i
have a good post on networking between
different services well yo thank you so
much thank you gabe for being here brian
as always thank you for being here and
if you're watching at home leave a
comment let us know anything new that
you've learned or picked up we
definitely check the comments thank you
so much that's the end of this one
[Music]
you